[Musique]
que c'est comme si vous louiez une
maison avec des amis vous êtes 10 vous
savez qu'il y a 60 ouvriers qui sont
morts pour la construire est-ce que vous
voudrez vraiment partir en vacances dans
cette maison de vacances je suis pas sûr
voilà c'est une des nombreuses
manifestations contre la tenue de la
Coupe du Monde de socket au Qatar Jean
Patrick c'est ça que c'est l'air tout ça
on va l'envoir probablement davantage on
a vu les joints aussi s'exprimer plus
sobrement mais quand même s'exprimer
effectivement ce que vous avez vu en
fait c'était au mois de mai dernier
c'est un groupe de manifestants qui ont
simulé un match de stocker avec un
ballon imbibé de sang du faux sang
évidemment mais tout ça pour dénoncer la
situation des travailleurs migrants qui
ont souffert durant la construction des
stades de la Coupe du Monde
un état qui est décrié depuis 10 ans en
fait depuis que la Coupe du Monde a été
attribuée au Qatar pourquoi regarder
dans les journaux ces travailleurs qui
mettent sur pied la Coupe du Monde c'est
le cas de le dire il y a un malaise ici
dans les caricatures celle-là elle dit
tout en fait on parle d'environnement
avec les stades qui sont climatisés
extérieurs l'argent et les décès de ces
travailleurs migrants il y a toutes
sortes de manifestations
pour cette Coupe du Monde controversée
où on dénonce la corruption le coût
environnemental et aussi le coût humain
de cette coupe du monde dans un pays où
il fait très chaud par-candrée le
commuter organisateur qui indiqué que
trois travailleurs avaient trouvé la
mort durant la construction des 8 stades
l'Organisation internationale du Travail
a enquêter elle elle parle de 50 morts
mais regardez l'enquête de The Guardian
le journal britannique qui parle de 6500
morts c'est un article qui était publié
en février 2021 gardé dans le coin ici
on dit révélation le coût humain du
projet de coupe du monde au Qatar bref
ça fait beaucoup jaser ces travailleurs
migrants pour la plupart de l'Inde du
Népal du Pakistan qui sont allés au
Qatar pour travailler 7 jours sur 7 12
heures par jour dans des conditions
incroyables on parle de 50 degrés la
plupart sont morts de chaleur dit aussi
des conditions de vie où on n'a pas
d'eau on mange mal on est mal nourri on
trois pays on n'est pas du tout payé
parfois et il y a un journaliste du
gardien qui voulait avoir la réaction
d'un des joueurs là-bas et regarder que
l'accueil on lui a réservé non non non
pas de commentaires alors c'est le genre
de choses qui nous arrivent quand on est
dans un pays comme le Qatar admetti
international qui a demandé réparation
440 millions pour les familles de ces
travailleurs qui ont trouvé la mort
pourquoi 440 c'est le montant qui
représente les bourses qui seront
remises au 32 clubs qui vont participer
à la Coupe du monde dont le Canada on a
demandé aussi des réformes du Code du
travail il y a un salaire minimum qui
était instauré mais il y a beaucoup de
de règles qui ne sont même pas
respectées sur les chantiers soccer
Canada quand même qui disait il y a
quelques jours on soutient la poursuite
continue de nouveaux progrès
relativement au droit des travailleurs
et à l'inclusion alors que le Qatar se
prépare accueillir le monde maintenant
le Qatar a réagi il sera pas question de
remettre 440 millions de dollars aux
travailleurs et
qui manifestent depuis plusieurs mois
regardez l'équipe allemande soutenons
les 30 30 les 30 articles de la
Déclaration des Droits Humains
maintenant du côté de la Norvège on
demande avec des chandails des
banderoles sur le terrain que les droits
humains soient respectés sur les
terrains et à l'extérieur des terrains
l'équipe du Danemark qui va porter un
chandail complètement rouge on voit plus
les commanditaires parce que personne va
être associé à cette coupe du monde et
en France il y aura aucun rassemblement
public pour voir les matchs durant la
Coupe du Monde on écoute là-dessus le
maire de Lyon
moi là je suis pas aujourd'hui en train
de vous annoncer un boycot je vous dis
voilà moi j'engage pas d'argent public
pour promouvoir une manifestation et
bien qu'à sacrifié autant de vie
qui a bafoué les droits humains et qui
aujourd'hui est bien sur le plan
environnemental est une abomination
on va pas assez de controverse à l'autre
la controverse de l'arbitrage et
regardez un ballon c'est peut-être le
temps de d'aller voir ce qui va se
passer pour cette Coupe du Monde c'est
un ballon qui s'appelle alrila qui dit
qu'on dit le voyageur ben alors tout
spécial avec un capteur à l'intérieur
qui va permettre de savoir où est le
ballon durant les matchs 29 capteurs
aussi sur chacun des joueurs on va
savoir où sont les joueurs tout ça pour
déterminer s'il y aura des hors-jeu
pendant les matchs 12 caméras au total
pour déterminer la position du ballon
des joueurs alors voilà tout est en
place pour aider les officiels durant
cette coupe du monde pour minimiser le
nombre de hors-jeu et de décisions
controversées je vous laisse sur des
images du fameux ballon Aria
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI